Donald Trump had another one of these gung
show rallies yesterday and he told a lot of
lies in the rally.
That's not really a survey
surprise, but he also said something that's
more than a lie or something that is more
interesting than just a lie or truth.
Either way, whether it's true or not, it's
idiotic.
Donald Trump was in Pittsburgh.
He was giving a speech about, I guess on paper
it was supposed to be about energy, but it's
Trump.
So it goes off the rails as usual.
And Donald Trump said that his administration
is already building a wall in New Mexico and
in Colorado, uh, hear it from the horse's
mouth himself.
Take a listen.
We're building a wall on the border of New
Mexico and we're building a wall in Colorado.
We're building a beautiful wall, a big one
that really works that you can't get over.
You can't get under it.
And we're building a wall in Texas and we're
not building a wall in Kansas, but they get
the benefit of the walls that we just mentioned.
He might end up needing to use a Sharpie to
modify a map, I guess, to put Colorado on
the Mexican border.
Now, if you look at a map, you might notice
that yes, New Mexico does share a little bit
of a border with Mexico, but the state of
Colorado does not.
So I don't know if Trump is trying to keep
people in Colorado because of that legal weed
or out of neighboring States.
We may never really know, and of course people
at Trump's rally, as you heard in that clip,
were cheering when Donald Trump said he was
building walls in New Mexico and Colorado.
Why are they cheering like are they just dumb?
Do they want a wall around Colorado separating
Colorado from other States?
What about Denver's huge international airport
into which planes can just fly over the wall
anyway, how does Donald Trump explain it?
It was all a joke.
Trump was making subtle jokes despite never
having shown evidence of the type of sense
of humor that would allow a subtle joke to
be made.
Donald Trump doing kiddingly.
We're building a wall in Colorado then stated
we're not building a wall in Kansas, but they
get the benefit of the wall we're building
on the border referred to people in the very
packed auditorium from Colorado and Kansas
getting the benefit of the border wall.
Um, can I, what does this guy talking about
what an obviously ridiculous explanation.
Now what's more likely Trump was using the
type of subtle in detectable humor, which
he's never displayed evidence of being capable
of, or Trump just had no idea where walls
were getting built.
If anywhere, maybe not getting built is more
like it and has only a limited understanding
of the geography of the United States.
The evidence says that the ladder is actually
more likely the people of Colorado, by the
way, are more or less sensible.
Maybe they are the ones building a wall to
keep Trump out.
Since Trump seems to think walls keep people
out, he might not realize if I want to go
to Colorado, I can just fly into the airport
over the wall, the best explanation.
Colorado borders New Mexico.
And maybe Trump is thinking that Colorado
should have a wall on its Southern border
with New Mexico for safety or something because
anything with the name Mexico in it clearly
is very, very dangerous.
Or something like that.
America in 2019 this is a, it's a sad place.
This is a reality.
Um, I, I is more analysis necessary or the
one question to you is, is there anything
else that I'm not accounting for that maybe
Donald Trump meant when he said, we're building
a wall around Colorado.
Let me know.
Uh, leave a response.
If you're watching on YouTube, send me a tweet
at D Pacman.